hey guys it looks great wonderful I'm
Greg album alvarado comedy is her
Facebook page and she's on Instagram and
Twitter at the cat Alvarado
she just headline her own show recently
stand-up comedy I'm gonna go see her for
a forum on Tuesday flappers flappers
September 5th I will be there if their
celebrity drop in show they had Adam
Sandler and Jerry Seinfeld there
recently whoa this might actually be
like really famous people it could be
actual famous people I don't know who
it's always a surprise you know what I
found out I haven't been watching the
Super Troopers 2 trailer because I have
a confession to make
haven't seen Super Troopers who know why
make the sound effect if you're really
slap me five times no not enough Kat has
seen the first Super Troopers we're
taking so long to play now let's make
sure you don't lean in too far my last
friend did that you're gonna do it
intentionally I feel it this is a
wonderful reaction here we go that's a
lot of reasons to be rated R whoa
seriously cut the crap guy marketís off
me it's not like we wanted to shave your
balls story do you want to shave off me
hello Foster no you don't want to shave
his balls do you farm oh hell yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
Corp hey hey you know before we filmed
cat was like you at least heard the meow
thing right nothing right now yeah yeah
and then she explained it to me
and I said like thanks cat that
information I'm sure will actually come
in handy and it dude good good cat yeah
that trailer just made me go why have I
not seen Super Troopers one yet that was
pretty funny it was pretty funny it's a
twists and turns you don't expect the
ending and all it's all kind of hijinks
like I would watch it I'm surprised you
enjoyed it it seems like such bro humor
you know sometimes I'm in the mood for
broke human yeah like dick jokes and all
that yeah I kind of sometimes right bro
ish humor I kind of think the first time
I saw you perform it was dude that was
one of your charming traits actually
okay so I guess the moral of the story
is it's really not a surprise at all
thank you enjoy super troopers yeah
these guys look really funny I like
seeing Brian Cox in here the guy who
yells at them I could already watch a
version a movie that is a version of
these guys from watching this trailer
for a sequel makes me go I got to watch
the first one yeah and so what they're
from Canada now is time around who are
they yeah they're Canadian improv troupe
oh yeah oh so they're in Canada in the
firt and super troopers I'm pretty sure
they are the Canada thing doesn't make
and it makes more sense it does I feel
like there's a maple syrup joke
somewhere in Super Troopers one but it
was so long ago that I cannot remember
okay but I bet it's there or maybe I'm
racist that's not racism Canada maple
syrup
Jim Gaffigan Zinn he was in the first
one too I don't remember but he has
brown hair that is crazy he said are you
guys the same ones who pulled me over
before so I'm assuming a reference is
the first one Wow it's it's a comedy
sequel doing a comedy sequel reminding
us of bits that we loved before
Oh brilliant brilliant stuff I'm gonna
watch the first Super Troopers are you
excited to see this movie Kat I sure AM
okay well you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
another notification you can ignore on
your phone Kat Alvarado Kat Alvarado
comedy it's Greg Alba and this is Kat
Alvarado with the cat Alvarado company
on Facebook motor at their cat Alvarado
Dona Instagram and Twitter where she
awesome honestly constantly talks about
loving Trump that's not what I says on
the twist